i spoke to you on the phone um i've got
an appointment with david
yourself are you sourcing depends how
good it is the main thing we're looking
for is to buy run down properties
that we can turn into small hmos
like three four five dead hmos um
and then refinance them basically
what everybody's looking for the only
difference is
we buy quick and don't mess about in
other news
we've got a nova rental rent secured
from yesterday we don't need more
interest
but we've got no money yeah we've got no
money
okay so we're getting rent to rent from
yesterday still let me see let me see
let me see
where is that shepherd's bush yeah oh
oh this is on that one yeah isn't that
one oh
dude that that that that's a good that's
a good one so have we got we've got
four rental rent deals secured from
yesterday two with
natalie and then those two you're
getting yourself
so we just need to sell the two that we
got we natalie get the money in
use that money to pay for your two yeah
which is going to give you which will
mean you'll be making from rent to rent
two thousand pound a month
yep when we're going these properties by
the way it's quick yeah in and out 10
10 minutes 15 minutes max no small talk
no talking about the weather and the dog
i mean is it specifically hmos are you
looking forward to stuff like that yeah
high gem has all
ones that we can convert into hmos
it's got a blue feature wall i mean
lower this house there's something about
this house
i don't think this is a gower
he doesn't need much money spent on it
it's already live sensor which means he
has grandfather rights
if yeah evans wants this house
he's upstairs negotiating man i want to
buy this house
come on i don't think so
evan evans yes
let's go man potentially you should want
to do a deal
yeah let's go i'm feeling really happy
about this he reckons he might accept
170
which is which is the bargain not for
this one the third of december he
accepted an offer for one seventy on
this
do you reckon do you reckon the buyers
disappeared because of some of the
things outside in the garden maybe
no the buyers disappear because we
should have never even listened to his
offer
sorry we've got to shoot we've got
another viewing but thanks for coming
out here we are back
i think we can get it though we're
talking the car
no shouldn't be funny but why'd you rush
me out at the house i used to be hmm
before you know that is
uh japanese not weird i think that was
in the house in the garden
in fact i don't think that was
that was that in the garden i reckon
that house is worth nothing
did you see so did you actually see that
in there yes okay well that wasn't
upstairs i looked up still there
these are the things you need to look
for man
he was so angry with me he was like once
you reach me at the house man i was i
was about to buy it i was that far off
from buying it i've got another view now
we do we'll drive next to you and you
just book some of you i'm actually there
today
i assume is today too soon for you sir
no
actually today would be great it's going
ahead at one o'clock so i can probably
get you in a
half one maybe all confirmed for half
one
three four if you enjoyed the book so
this is the property
all right this is one of you know 11 45
this is way better than right now the
app is yeah there's a lot of interest
because
i can't i can't see there being enough
profit in it for us
as developers it needs to like
financially make sense for us
what do you think would be the lowest
offer that you can accept and still be
able to live with so it was upon
offering you know roughly about 125 do
you think that's something that
you guys would accept how did you feel
that when
i mean i think we'd have to get that for
a minimum of 120.
yeah why don't we go to a hotel we're
not getting more viewings and
um trying to sell that rent to rent
there from yesterday because that needs
to go today we need we need we need the
money back from those two rent events
uh we obviously have to leave a preview
in all later so it's not going to be
today probably going to be tomorrow
but that's in the back you haven't got
so they want the money now the rent to
rent wants the money
evans is trying to sell the rent to rent
deals right now walking around on the
phone
if she wants to at 50 no problem but she
has to
completely refurb the house so tomorrow
needs to be a big win
we've got two rent to rent but we need
the money to pay for them he's trying to
sell the deals now i might go and help
him in a minute doesn't make financial
sense with
you know upon one and two seven it
literally doesn't i'll tell you why
because it needs to be re-gutted like
the property's in a really bad condition
it's a bit of a difficult day you know
samuel's
watch him he's taking selfies
everything's okay but
we realistically got nothing in the bag
you know yes we secured two rents
and does well we haven't paid for them
because we meant to pay for them the two
dollars we got to sell but we've got no
money in the bank
send me those bank details over i'll get
that done within within the next
literally 120 seconds right and if you
could also send me that pack
or that email that would be really
helpful i'll call you back in 20 minutes
fantastic sounds grip doing it right now
babe thank you speak to you
all right yeah
he's got half a million that is
awesome tick tick tick tell me the truth
now were you feeling bummed out earlier
i wasn't honest you weren't i was
honestly i wasn't okay
i wasn't man i brought i i'm an optimist
always
i always always see the good okay okay
[Laughter]
today's been a little bit better than
yesterday i actually sold the deal
i've got the money physically in the
bank um
samuel is saying that i go sell two more
and one minimum
your job get that sick get that to get
that three round up for six grand
yeah and uh twenty we need to leave it
about ten minutes so i wanna quickly get
changed okay well the good job man three
thousand pound is not bad
yeah we need that to be six okay a
minimum
six feeling good yeah all right welcome
back
closing closing closing money money
money so based on what i've said to you
is there anything else that you need for
me to make a decision
uh well what i would like to meet up and
and
um you know what are you doing and
i know it's a little bit forward but i
don't know if we could take take the fee
off you up front
but have a contract in place that says
that if we
if we don't get a deal over the line
within the next 14 days
um we'll we'll then refund you and then
we can dedicate because we've had so
many people saying we want it we want it
we want it but it's just like
you know it's hard to distinguish who's
serious and who's not if that makes
sense
i completely understand sam uh samuel um
no that's perfectly fine at the end of
the day this is a business
all right evans if you pick over terms
and conditions as soon as you've
responded to the terms and conditions
and agreed well uh evans will send over
the invoice for two nine nine five
that's including your fees and
everything
and um and once we get the deal in the
bag as part of the service evans will
hold your hand
he'll walk you through everything help
you set it all up because it's your
first one and because we want to see you
succeed yes thank you very much
that means that'll be probably six
that'll be six thousand pounds in your
bank which means you can then
pay for your two rent to rent deals i've
got another one in the bag oh
good did that be nine thousand by the
time we finished the day
[Laughter]
so my first deal was a lot harder
[Music]
now it's a lot more simpler now i've got
the contracts
i've now got the terms and conditions
the practical i know what to say i know
what questions to ask
i've actually sold studios in the last
few hours i've got the third one pending
now i've got the knowledge and i know
how to do it here's the most amazing
things i never have to fill out a job
application ever again
knowledge is key this area feels rough
but there's a ranger
packed in there it's got all the windows
not broken
yeah that's probably someone like us
doing a viewing i think it's this one
these windows man you know i feel like
if i just like literally threw this down
on the floor it wouldn't matter that's
the sign the area is bad when you feel
like it wouldn't matter by throwing
junk on the floor
we'll only be like five minutes tops
another repossession
needs a lot of work i reckon it needs at
least twenty thousand
yeah this is a definitely needs a big
lot of work
so nasty room bit of damp
might even potentially be some
structural issues i'm not sure but it
does feel
a little bit that way too bad
problem is this is on for 55 000 we'd
spend 20 000 on it
and then the new value would be 75 000
so we wouldn't be able to really add
value when you're doing a refurb every
time you spend a pound you want to be
adding three pounds
can't see it happening no so it's a big
fat
steamy smelly no how did the last
what did the last person think of this
they like it no
no i think i think i would agree with
them with a capital n
it's a no with a capital n but uh hey
thank you so much
have yourself a wonderful day good to
meet you
we've got lots on today you've got
something on your
chest
so is this is this a repossession this
one yeah yeah yeah
it's nice it doesn't need that much work
does it
oh i think this is a good one
room big nice one sweet ensuite
room room bathroom room
wc four rooms
95 grand in the area they're selling for
like 115.
around here it was previously bought 440
145 but then when we possessed
imagine when we buy and we can do it up
and get it looking nice it's gonna be
worth probably like 120.
what do you think of this as an investor
would you like to own this house
definitely it definitely doesn't need
much work it's in a very good area
you could do the work yourself
absolutely you could say to the
joint venture investors you could say
i'll do the refurb for free
you could pay for the refurb so you
could say need to refurb it it's every
possession but i'll pay for the
you put the 95 grand in i'll pay for the
refurb
i'll find it i'll do everything i'll
manage it will go 50 50.
i'm still bad i reckon you could you
could do this all right okay we can
there's no not weed thank you so much
that is a good one so the house is in
the area
they're all selling for like about 115.
we get that for about 95 grand 96 grand
about 20 grand below market value
it does need a refurb but with evan's
refurb skills
from um the eviction i'm pretty
confident he could do the whole thing up
for like two or three grand
absolutely if we could rent that out as
a hmo that's that's a good
solid investment there rented out
to the uh 30 to the first of july of
next year yeah
so it's ready for about nine and a half
grand a year or something yes
not yeah i need to call it ten thousand
pounds and it's actually rented out from
the first of july
of next year for another year wow so
it's rented out to the 30th of june
2022 yep that's great i mean it's on for
110
are you are you going to hold out for
that are you open to negotiations at all
what we've done is we put it on on a
figure
that we think is a good figure for what
it is it's an investment
property it's somebody that doesn't have
to do anything so they can come in here
and they can say is it ready to go yes
it is ready to go have we got guarantors
in place yes we have
is that ever that everything is in
situations from day one
there's nothing that you need to spend
and you know that your income
is there to the 1st of
july 20 22.
nice to have an intelligent conversation
with a local investor that understands
the crack
why is it that we didn't offer we didn't
ask him was the lowest again
he's willing to accept if we pay cash
because
i wanted to show him how awesome and
credible we are so that when we do put
our offer forward through the agent
he goes i like those guys they won't
mess around i need to accept our offer
i personally don't think we should buy
it but i think we should sell it it's
making 10 grand a year
gross yeah 110 000 he likes us a lot
you can add an extra room in time yeah
tenants in there until 2022 good return
i reckon we could sell that why'd you
wait why do you not think we should buy
it
to buy it we need to raise finance or
find the joint venture partner
which is hard and i think it although
it's good
i still prefer the one that we viewed
this morning his money's going to be
stuck in there
his money's going to be stuck in there i
want a brr